[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a japanese short film
called the beauty tax
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the movie begins in a japanese office
where the manager yells at everyone for
not being good enough at their jobs
however when a beautiful woman aiko
makes a mistake he lets her off the hook
and even apologizes for being rude
aiko's co-workers are not very fond of
her because no matter how hard they work
the manager only ever favors her not
just at work but wherever they go people
give aaiko extra attention at lunch only
she gets a complimentary pudding while
returning home from work a salesman
gives her two packets of free products
while the others get one packet per two
people for aiko it is a normal day
because she is used to getting special
treatment somewhere else in a press
conference the prime minister announces
that the financial condition of the
country is in a complicated situation
hence to cope with this problem the
government has decided to enforce a new
law in which the attractive women of the
country will have to pay a beauty tax
the protesters in the audience claim
that this is modern-day systemic
discrimination against women but the
prime minister claps back saying that
beautiful women receive a lot of
financial privileges which is not fair
for ugly people he declares that the law
will soon be enforced and the ones who
try to avoid the beauty tax will be
punished beautiful women probably have
nothing to worry about as they don't
have to pay for anything to begin with
some days later aiko is approached by a
man who offers her a modeling job for a
beauty salon her colleagues jealous of
her popularity walk away as aiko follows
them the camera pans towards a newspaper
headline that says the beauty tax has
been enacted when the three go for lunch
that day aiko's co-workers pay a
thousand yen for their food however aiko
is asked to stand in front of a scanning
device the device is supposed to scan
women and measure what percentage of tax
they should pay according to their
beauty aiko poses for the machine and it
scans her face the results say that she
is the second level of beauty so she
should pay 20
beauty tax her total comes out to 1200
yen which she reluctantly pays the
restaurant that used to provide her with
free complimentary desserts is now
making her pay extra just because she is
beautiful
later while buying a bottle of water
aiiko again has to pay more than a
normal person likewise all the pretty
girls of the nation according to the
level of their attractiveness have to
pay a certain amount of tax
the news reporters interview common
people about their thoughts on the tax
enactment and people seem to be quite
happy about it one man claims that he
has spent a lot of money on pretty girls
so it is only fair if they have to pay
more taxes than him another not so
pretty girl states that the beautiful
ones were getting pampered so it is only
appropriate if they have to pay more
before the law was enacted many people
thought of it as discrimination towards
women but after it was enforced the
people have changed sides now most of
the nation is in favor of the beauty tax
the next day aiko receives her paycheck
and excitedly opens it only to be
disappointed the money on the check is a
lot less than her actual salary she goes
to the manager with the concern and
finds out that the beauty tax also
applies to her salary which means she
will get 20 less than what she used to
the manager calmly explains to her that
it is not his fault but the government's
to make her feel better he offers to
treat her with meals whenever he can
enraged by the discrimination aiko and
the other beautiful women of the city
hold up signs and protest at the tax
enforcement office the man there asks
them to go away because the decision has
been made and it is definite aiko
retaliates that this is the worst form
of discrimination but the man claps back
claiming that they have had the pretty
privilege he asks aiko to give it a
thought and dismisses the matter when
aiiko thinks about it she slowly begins
to realize she has had pretty privilege
all her life she remembers when she was
little she broke a flower pot once the
adults used to get mad at the children
for doing the same thing but their
reaction was different for her in
college her friends didn't let her pay
for meals anytime they went out just
because of her beauty and even now at
work her boss pardons all of her
mistakes but he gets annoyed when others
do the same
back in the present the officer states
that beautiful girls like her have
always had social and economical
benefits which are unfair to others
hence the beauty tax is a reasonable law
that ensures fairness
to make aiko feel better he adds that
her beauty has been recognized
throughout the country by the standard
set by the government
looking at the situation from a
different perspective aiko starts to
feel better about the 20 tax the
narrative changes when the girls who pay
higher taxes start to be seen as the
better ones in society aiko even goes to
a reality television show and expresses
her happiness at being one of the few
people who pay 20 beauty tax the girls
say that they are being asked out often
at restaurants and bars when guys find
out that they pay beauty tax even at
aiko's work her popularity skyrockets
and she starts being known as the girl
who pays 20 beauty tax unlike her
previous interaction with restaurant
cashiers now aiko is delighted to pay
more money for being beautiful her
manager calls her when he has important
business meetings and his business
partner signs the papers without
hesitation after seeing aiko's beautiful
face
while purchasing things she makes sure
to emphasize that she pays a twenty
percent tax to those around her who only
pay five percent when aiko receives her
paycheck instead of getting mad she is
flattered and considers it the fate of a
beautiful woman she is thriving more
than ever until raikou tajima arrives at
her office riko pays 25 beauty tax
making her more beautiful than aiko by
law her colleagues all follow riko
around claiming that she is prettier
than any celebrity they have seen aiko
is stung by jealousy to see all the men
drool over riko because she is used to
being the center of attention she vows
to be prettier than reiko in some days
then she starts to exercise day and
night in hopes of losing weight she also
goes to spas daily and receives several
expensive facial treatments after a lot
of hard work she goes to a restaurant
and scans herself to find out that she
now has to pay 30
tax aeko jumps in happiness to have
finally gotten prettier than riko but
when she looks at her bank balance her
happiness vanishes to see only two yen
left her day gets worse when she hears
about riko's plastic surgery at first
she believes reiko might have gotten
plastic surgery to be prettier but is
shocked when she gets a look at her face
riko had surgery to become less
attractive she looks completely
different than she used to it turns out
that her fiance left her because she was
too expensive to take care of as aiko
thinks that her day couldn't get worse
she is summoned by her manager who
informs her that she has been fired it
turns out that the company had to pay
more taxes for every beautiful employee
and to cut the unnecessary expenditure
they have decided to fire all the
beautiful people
soon the narrative around the beauty tax
changes again beauty products that make
women seem uglier start selling out the
people who were proud to pay more
because of their beauty start making
themselves uglier to keep their jobs
moreover men start to avoid beautiful
women because their cost of living is
too damn high one day aiko is in the bar
distressed about her life a man
approaches her and offers help to get
her taxes lowered before she can
continue the conversation aiko gets a
call from their family lawyer it turns
out that her dead mother has left her
with a lot of wealth that she inherited
from her uncle however the beauty tax
also applies to inheritances since
aiko's mother was also very beautiful
the inheritance amounts to negative 1
million yen meaning that if aiko wants
to claim the inheritance she will have
to pay the government and receive
nothing at night aiko goes to the bar
again and meets the same guy he
introduces himself as nonomura aiko and
nonomura get closer while talking he
suggests she make herself look ugly to
avoid taxes and even hands her fake
thick eyebrows aiko is a little
skeptical because avoiding paying taxes
might put her in jail but nonomura
assures her many girls do the same the
next day aiko draws thick lashes and
freckles all over her face as a man with
thick brows and freckles this offends me
she also hides her beautiful hair with a
short wig and adds a huge mole to her
nose the tax officer is startled to see
her come in she claims that she has been
stressed because of her mother's death
and has gained some weight the officer
scans her and the machine declares her
ugly he finally takes aiko off the
pretty women list which means she will
no longer have to pay for the
inheritance tax thinking that all of her
problems are solved she rushes outside
and calls nonomura he congratulates her
and invites her to meet his parents in a
nice dress aiiko understands that the
man is interested in her and smiles to
herself she is happy that even in a time
like this someone is in need of her
beauty on the day they are supposed to
go out aiko excitedly does her makeup
however her plans go in vain when two
policemen knock on her door and arrest
her for trying to be ugly to avoid
paying taxes they also inform her that
nonomura is a notorious marriage
swindler who covets the inheritance of
beautiful women it turns out that he was
never interested in her beauty and was
only trying to get her inheritance aiko
is then sentenced to two years in prison
she is depressed and alone as her life
has taken a turn for the worse her only
friend in the prison is her cellmate who
is also in for trying to be ugly and
avoiding taxes as they talk aiko wishes
that she was born ugly if only her nose
was one centimeter shorter her life
might have turned out differently but
her cellmate advises her to never turn
away from reality she claims that they
both are unhappy right now because of
their dull hearts not because of their
beauty according to her they were too
focused on having a pretty face and they
forgot to keep their heart happy aiko is
inspired by her new friend's words she
vows to work on beautifying her heart
when she gets out cut to two years later
aiko is finally let out of prison she is
dedicated to working on her heart this
time she sees a kid crying for ice cream
and kindly offers to buy one for her
however the shopkeeper returns her extra
money saying that she isn't pretty
enough for beauty tax moreover some kids
from behind her call her ugly hearing
this the beautification of heart leaves
aiko's mind she gets offended claiming
that she is still very beautiful but it
turns out that in the last two years the
standard of beauty has changed
completely since men favored ugly women
because of the beauty tax they became
more popular and are now considered more
beautiful than traditionally beautiful
women
amazed at the new world aiiko hands the
kid her ice cream but she refuses to
accept it because of aiiko's ugliness
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching